what's going on people it's Jake and
welcome to another video where we talk
about Elden ring DLC to fill the void
until we can actually play it I asked
you guys what questions you wanted the
DLC to answer in terms of the lore but
most of the questions that we got if
this can even be considered a question
were like this one from buffoonis who
asked I want to know when the DLC is
coming that's all you know I've heard a
few different things on this I've heard
that we could get the DLC sometime after
armed core 6 releases within the range
of a month or deep into the next year
I'm leaning more toward next year I
think it would be such an insane grind
for from software to release armored
Core 6 and then Elden ring DLC anytime
soon after that not to mention it would
be kind of a bad idea for them to do so
it would bring a lot of attention off
their brand new ac6 game which I
seriously doubt they want to do I know I
would stop everything I was doing to
play Elden ring DLC even if I was
halfway through an armored Core 6
playthrough and this actually goes well
into our next question why hasn't it
come out yet well hopefully it's because
they're making this the biggest DLC that
we've ever seen in gaming up to this
point it's been well over a year since
the game was released and all we've
gotten is this picture with no release
date on it I'm a firm believer that from
software wasn't really planning on
making any DLC for Elden ring until they
saw how successful it was we all know it
went way over their expectations and
there's some good evidence that they
didn't start development on the DLC
until April of last year which was a
good couple of months after the initial
release I also believe that mowgun's
Palace and the Halo tree were meant to
be the future DLCs of Elden ring but
they ultimately decided to just finish
off these areas and just add them into
the main game the way we access these
areas are exactly along the lines of how
past games from chrome software
introduced us to the new DLC areas
whether it's doing a small puzzle or
following a questline it definitely
matches up and honestly I don't care how
long it takes I'm just happy they're
even making a DLC in the first place and
I'm excited to play it but sometime soon
would be great of course I want to see
if Nikola is actually evil or became
corrupted by Mo's interference what
happened to his great Rune if he claimed
one personally I think nikola's story is
going to be exactly like the story of
Griffith from berserk which is one of
the few anime that I actually like
nothing against anime it's just not my
thing for the most part but based on
everything that we can infer from the
game mikola was well loved by almost
everybody and was constantly trying to
find a cure for the burdens that he and
his family were afflicted by the
greatest example of this is obviously
his twin sister Melania and her Scarlet
rot with his creation of analoid gold
which would hold back the spread of the
rot that was quite literally causing
Melania to lose most of her limbs there
could be many reasons why mikola created
the halog tree but my theory ultimately
lands on mikola actually failing to help
himself and his sister during the end
and in a last-ditch effort gave himself
to Moog to hopefully grow himself into
more than just a child we can see in the
opening cut scene that he is very small
and frail compared to Moog whereas in
moguin's Palace he is much larger I have
a hunch that Moog was actually talking
to the blood within the body of the
Cocoon when referring to mikola and this
body is not actually mikola but is just
a host for the blood that Moog and the
formless mother need I have a full video
on this called Nicholas dream which you
should go watch if you're curious about
this full Theory I think it's a good one
who is torrent however ninety percent of
the questions won't be answered in both
Miyazaki and George R and Martin will
just sit back and allow us to decide
whatever lore we want you guys really
think this like they just left it all up
in the air with everything on purpose
you know I get it I definitely feel that
way sometimes myself but when I do I
know I'm digging a little bit too deep
with questions that actually don't need
to be answered which I think is
important to understand there are simply
things that don't have an answer in this
game and that's fine there is so much of
that in real life where we have
questions and we just never receive an
answer to them in regards to torrent
there isn't much that we're given on him
we know he's been through the ringer
with previous owners who are trying to
go on this long journey of achieving the
ultimate goal of reaching the Eldon ring
along this path he must have met with
Melina and Ronnie as they are the only
two other characters that even reference
the existence of torrent and he chooses
us to be the next one to go on this
journey with also have you noticed that
torrent has a scar under his left eye
along with some pretty serious burns on
his left side remind you of anybody else
I think torrent has been around a very
long time and as a spirit he's likely
looking for the final path back to the
ERD tree so that he can move on to
whatever comes next I think this is the
biggest lore reason why we can't use
torrent during the final boss fight even
though the eldenbeast fight is total dog
and is a very much improved if you
can use torrent to run down the
eldenbeast when he swims away like you
can in the convergence mod and if you
guys haven't played the convergence mod
yet you should absolutely do so if you
own a PC it literally makes the game way
better it's amazing knowing Miyazaki by
the end of the DLC we will have more
questions than answers I understand the
frustration at the deeper meanings of
the lore being extremely complicated but
I disagree that the past DLCs that
Miyazaki and from software have released
made us more confused than we were
before if anything the DLC has expanded
heavily on the lore and answered a ton
of questions yes new theories were
crafted from these DLCs but the overall
story was expanded on and very well
explained in many ways it's sort of
unfortunate that we had to experience
the DLCs of Dark Souls 3 for example in
the order that we did if you played on
release and waited for the DLCs of Ashes
of Arendelle and the ring City if you
played let's say a year here or really
any time after the DLCs were released
you got to experience the totality of
Dark Souls 3's lore in the order that
makes the most sense to the overall
story likely leading to a much more
satisfying ending because the DLCs can
be accessed pretty early on in the main
game of Dark Souls 3 you could enter
Ash's of ariandel and while likely
getting your ass kicked if you're there
too early you could still start to piece
some things together just by exploring
the DLC areas and coming back later when
you're stronger I have to believe that
eldenring will have a similar path to
entering the DLC meaning it won't be
required for you to beat the game for
example to enter the DLC you'll instead
just have to come across it in the main
world and will be able to gain access to
the new area by interacting with
something a lot of people have been
hinting that Nicholas hand will be the
entrance to the DLC for Elden ring
however mowgun's Palace can only be
accessed by completing Varys questline
or entering through the the way gate in
the consecrated snow fields not to
mention you have to beat Moog which I
consider an in-game optional boss
compared to the main game not exactly
easy to do and will likely piss off some
new Souls players who paid 15 to 20
dollars to play the DLC even though they
never even got past Market entering the
DLC this way is still possible in fact
it's very likely since the ashes of
ariandel DLC was accessed a little less
than halfway through the main game and
several bosses were required to be
beaten before you could access it then
to play the ringed City DLC you had to
complete the first DLC by beating a
three-stage extremely difficult sister
free to boss fight definitely not an
easy thing to do but is obviously a
skill and damage check before entering a
new much more difficult area I feel like
a lot of players will likely think that
they'll buy the DLC and see a new option
in the main menu to just go play the DLC
since they pay made money to play it
that's not going to happen or at least I
very much doubt it but this is from
software's first open world game so I
should be open to all possibilities but
I am ready for all the drama to come out
when the DLC does as well it's not like
you're gonna get your questions answered
in this game anyway trash storytelling
listen Buck if you're paying any
attention to the story it's really not
that complicated to understand you're a
nobody tarnished who has been called
back to the lands between by the greater
will because they literally don't have
any other options all the demigods have
abandoned them and lost their you
are tasked with restoring the Elden ring
so that the world can go back to how it
was before Queen America shattered it
that's pretty much it it's easy to
understand since you are told all of
this in the opening cut scene now
everything else and understanding why
all of this is going on is much more
difficult but is still there for you to
interpret yourself based on your own
experience through the game and even
your own moral to come to your own
conclusions that is not trash
storytelling that's treating you as a
player that can think for themselves
instead of a baby that has to be spoon
fed information like every other boring
game that comes out lately will it have
a new ending I think we definitely will
get a new ending my theory is that we'll
have a new quest line to complete after
talking with mikola to learn more about
their backstory and intentions this
version of Michelob that we see in the
shadow of the earth tree image I have a
hard time believing we will fight
against in any way it'd make much more
sense to me that our relationship with
mikola will be like that of Ronnie where
it'll have its own quest line and will
lead to a new ending what that ending
will be I have no idea there are so many
avenues that mikola could lead us down
it is insane but I think we will
definitely fight the version of Nikola
that is in the Cocoon and of course
Godwin either in his normal form or this
scary scaly fish-like creature that we
see in the deep root depths thanks for
watching guys I have a bunch of new
ideas for video discussions like this
coming out soon videos like does
bloodborne need a sequel will we ever
get a Souls game again my honest
thoughts on Dark Souls 2 I I just beat
Dark Souls 2 so I I wanted to make a
full video on my thoughts on it Lords of
the falling looks badass and why does
Melania attack us if any of these
interests you let me know your thoughts
and what you'd want to see first I hope
you enjoyed it and I'll see you all in
the next one take care